the hardest thing was family i um i miss
my family because
i came here as a 20 year old
with the baby
where i come from
you know that phrase it takes a village
to raise a child that's exactly how we
practice
but coming here i had to grow up very
quickly and learn
to look after my baby on my own and
yeah that was that was scary
most helpful was planket planked group
that was amazing
because i came here and my mother-in-law
took me straight to the blanket to the
plunkett ness
and um we got introduced to plunkett
nurse and she said oh there's a group of
um
young moms who set up this group and i
think their children are all the same
age as your children as your baby so you
can go and join in and that was the best
thing that ever happened because then i
started meeting moms who had this um
same age group as my baby and we were
sharing the same experience and stuff i
mean it was still hard culture wise
because you know i was
i was a foreigner but we connected
because of
because of our babies